Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Der TSV 1860 München entzieht drei Medien die Dauerakkreditierung und setzt damit einen neuen Höhepunkt in seinem Medienboykott. Darüber spreche ich mit Filippo Cartaldo, Ressortleiter Sport bei der Schwäbischen Zeitung. Hi Filippo, schön, dass es geklappt hat.
Ja wunderbar, ich freue mich auch total. Danke für die Einladung, auch wenn ich jetzt gar nicht mehr in Bayern bin, sondern am Bodensee und mir das Ganze so von außen anschaue. Aber auch schön.
Du, ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, das ist wie bei Trump, man kann froh sein, wenn man gerade nicht am Ort ist, wo das geschehen ist.
Ja vielleicht, vielleicht. Aber es betrifft uns trotzdem, deswegen ist die Trump-Parallele gar nicht so verkehrt.
Ja, inwiefern betrifft euch denn das Kodlmuddel beim TSV?
Ja, also mich betrifft das jetzt irgendwie arbeitstechnisch schon ein bisschen, weil ich hier, Schwäbische Zeitung ist so Bodensee, Oberschwaben, Allgäu, das heißt, es gibt sogar Löwenfans hier in der Region, werden immer weniger, aber das ist ja auch so ein Zeichen, das ist ja so ein generelles Ding, auch in München werden es immer weniger. Also mich betrifft das arbeitstechnische, das heißt, ich muss mich jetzt mit einem Verein beschäftigen, mit dem ich mich eigentlich sehr lange nicht mehr beschäftigt hatte und eigentlich auch ganz froh war, dass ich mich beruflich nicht mehr mit ihm beschäftigen musste. Und dann kommt halt dazu, dass ich eigentlich mal Löwe war, Löwenfan war, so als Kind. Das hat sich dann komplett verloren, als ich dann Reporter war. Dann kam es wieder so ein bisschen und jetzt ringe ich halt total mit mir, weil eigentlich es ist halt einfach nicht mehr mein, es kann nicht mehr mein Verein sein. Also alles, was da passiert ist, ist extrem schwierig und es ist so ein bisschen, ja, verlorene Liebe und dann sagt man sich, vielleicht hätte ich es einfach dabei belassen sollen, dass ich halt einfach kein Fan eines Vereins mehr war, glücklicherweise. Und vielleicht war das besser und so weiter.
Ja, aber so ganz kann man sich ja nicht davon lösen. Es ist ja schon mal erstaunlich, dass du es während deiner journalistischen Zeit so gut ausblenden konntest und diese Zweifel, mein Gott, das gibt es bei vielen Vereinen. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema, lass uns über Sechzig sprechen. Der Grund, warum ich jetzt dazu diesen Kurzpass machen will, ist, dass da jetzt eine neue Eskalationsstufe eingetreten ist, nachdem schon im November Sechzig generell die Medien boykottiert hat und sich ein selbst erlegtes Schweigeverbot oder Schweigegebot auferlegt hat. Haben Sie jetzt drei Medien? Genau, Medien durften das Trainingsgelände nicht mehr betreten. Gibt es jetzt drei Medien, nämlich Bild München, TZ und Münchner Merkur, denen die Dauerakkreditierung entzogen wurde. Für alle Hörer, die nicht so tief in den journalistischen Gepflogenheiten drin sind, kannst du vielleicht erst mal kurz erklären, was bedeutet das eigentlich, Dauerakkreditierung?
Also Dauerakkreditierung ist so eine Geschichte, das machen Vereine, eigentlich alle Vereine in der Bundesliga und der zweiten Liga, auch in der dritten Liga, das ist einfach zur vereinfachten Arbeit. Das heißt, alle Medien, die irgendwie ansässig sind und regelmäßig in den Stadien sind, bekommen am Anfang der Saison auf Antrag praktisch eine Akkreditierungskarte oder auch mehrere, die für alle Heimspiele gilt. Damit spart man sich eben, dass man jede Woche oder bei englischen Wochen, vielleicht sogar zweimal in der Woche ein Formular ausfüllen muss, das man dem Verein schicken muss, der Verein sich das anschaut und dann irgendwie bewilligt. Es ist einfach eine Arbeitserleichterung. Es gibt keinen rechtlichen Anspruch auf diese Dauerkreditierung. Es ist von der DFL so auch nicht im Wegewerk vorgesehen. Es ist halt ein Gentlemen's Agreement, den es aber schon immer gab.
Das heißt, was bedeutet es dann, wenn der Verein bestimmten Medien, ja nicht allen Medien, nur bestimmten, die Dauerkreditierung entzieht? Was ist da deine Interpretation?
Na ja, erstmal ist das irgendwie total seltsam, weil, wie gesagt, das ist eine Geschichte. Also diese Dauerkreditierungen wurden eingeführt aus Bequemlichkeit von beiden Seiten, weil natürlich der Verein auch nicht so interessiert ist, ständig diese Papierdinger zu bekommen, um die dann, also vor allem noch per Fax oft, und die dann zu genehmigen. Es besteht weiterhin die Möglichkeit, sich für Tagesakkreditierungen zu besorgen, hat Sechzig angekündigt. Dann wird man natürlich sehen, also ich gehe davon aus, dass die betroffenen Kollegen sich natürlich akkreditieren werden fürs nächste Heimspiel. Und wenn dann der Verein die Akkreditierungen ablehnt, dann hätten wir einen richtigen Vorgang, weil das geht eigentlich nicht. Also es ist, es liegt nicht, es sieht auch die DSL so vor, es liegt nicht im Ermessen des Vereins, Journalisten auszuschließen, weil ihnen die Nasen nicht passen.
Das heißt, wenn man noch dazunimmt, was der Verein 1860 als Begründung mitgegeben hat, nämlich, Zitat, wir haben uns für diesen Schritt entschieden, da wir aufgrund der Berichterstattung in den letzten Wochen und Monaten derzeit keine Basis für eine partnerschaftliche Zusammenarbeit mit diesen Medien sehen, Zitat, Ende, und wir gleichzeitig wissen, naja, erstmal ist ja nichts passiert in dem Sinne, dass...
Darum geht es erstmal gar nicht. Ich würde es gar nicht mal sagen, dass nichts passiert ist. Das stimmt schon auch, aber die Begründung, die sie anführen, sie sehen keine Basis mehr für eine partnerschaftliche Zusammenarbeit. Da muss man einfach sagen, da hat der Mensch, der dieses Verbot ausgestochen hat, nicht begriffen, was Journalisten eigentlich leisten. Es ist nicht unsere Aufgabe, wir sind nicht Partner des Vereins. Wir Journalisten waren nie Partner eines Vereins, sollten keine Partner eines Vereins sein. Und das ist einfach, das darf weder der Anspruch eines Vereins sein, noch der Anspruch eines Journalisten sein. Insofern ist das schon mal die gesamte Argumentationskette ist Bullshit. Journalisten sind Beobachter, Journalisten sind Berichterstatter, sind im Zweifel auch kritische Berichterstatter begleiten dieses Geschehen dort. Wie gesagt, im Zweifel auch kritisch, aber erstens sind sie Beobachter. Partner sind Sponsoren, Partner sind Freunde, aber Journalisten sind keine Partner, so geht es schon mal los. Die andere Geschichte ist natürlich, dass diese Akkreditierungsentzug so doof und aktionistisch sie ist und so seltsam sie ist, völlig willkürlich jetzt drei Zeitungen trifft, die natürlich in den letzten Wochen und Monaten ein wenig kritisch berichtet haben, die aber jetzt nicht kritischer berichtet haben als zum Beispiel die Abendzeitung, die nicht davon betroffen ist oder die süddeutsche Zeitung. Im Gegenteil, die Süddeutsche waren die kritischsten von allen, weil sie eben Dinge aufgedeckt haben. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, persönlich, dass sie das Recht sich darauf verzichtet hat, der Süddeutschen die Akkreditierung zu entziehen, weil sie Angst hatten, dass dann die Kollegen mit einer neuen Enthüllung kommen. Ich weiß es nicht, aber das ist so meine Erklärung dafür, dass die Süddeutsche ihre Akkreditierung behalten durfte.
Also, es ist ja natürlich vollkommen richtig, dass du das so einordnest, aber ist das jetzt eine Drohgebärde oder wie würdest du das interpretieren?
Ja, also erstmal ist es eine Drohgebärde. Erstmal wirkt das für mich oder auf mich unglaublich hilflos. Dass es peinlich ist, da müssen wir nicht überreden. Ich glaube, das ist irgendwie so ein unglaublich hilfloser Versuch, sich jetzt irgendwie zu positionieren und zu sagen, wir können noch anders. Der Journalistenverband protestiert ja jetzt schon. Ich glaube, zu einem richtigen Vorgang, also zu einem richtigen Vorgang, gegen den man dann auch wirklich protestieren müsste und dann auch dagegen vorgehen müsste, würde es tatsächlich werden, wenn jetzt einzelne Journalisten keine Tagesakkreditierungen mehr bekommen würden, aufgrund ihrer Berichterstattung. In Klammern, die Löwen haben keinerlei Artikel genannt oder keinerlei Beweise angeführt für diese ach so kritische Berichterstattung oder diese nicht partnerschaftliche Berichterstattung, sondern es ist einfach mal ein Vorwurf, der so in den Daumen geworfen wird.
Also der Bayerische Journalistenverband nennt es Pressepolitik nach Gutsherrenart, das ist jetzt ein Zitat, und der BJV-Vorsitzende Michael Busch sagt, das wäre unsäglich dieses Verhalten. Was glaubst du denn steckt dahinter? Also interessanterweise haben wir ja geradezu merkwürdige Parallelen aus der Weltpolitik, den Vergleich habe ich ja selber schon gebracht, jetzt hin zu dem Verhalten eines Vereins. Dass es unsouverän ist, das hast du schon genannt. Auch eine gewisse Unsicherheit steckt dahinter. Aber wie kommt man denn eigentlich überhaupt auf den Gedanken, damit für eine Verbesserung der eigenen Positionen sorgen zu können? Denn eigentlich müsste einem doch klar sein, dass man sich damit nur ins eigene Bein schießen kann.
Ja, sollte man meinen. Also Spiegel Online hat gerade eine Geschichte. Spiegel Online ist jetzt nicht das Medium, das irgendwie regelmäßig über den TSV 68 München berichten würde. Da lautet die Überschrift, das T steht für totalitär. Also totalitärer Sportverein München. Statt Turnsportverein München. Ja, also es geht schon in die Richtung. Es ist so eine Gemengenlage, das beobachten wir schon seit Jahren. Wir Journalisten seit zwei, drei Jahren. Also anders, es war immer schwierig bei 60. Es war als Reporter, auch der Umgangston zwischen Deportern und Verantwortlichen des TSV 1860 war nie ganz einfach. Bei 60 gab es in der Vergangenheit leider auch die Tendenz von Deportern, sich teilweise auch in die Vereinspolitik einzumischen, selber Politik zu machen. Also das muss man schon auch ein bisschen selbstständig sehen. Es sind viele Fehler von beiden Seiten gemacht worden, aber das ist alles schon sehr, sehr lange her. Der Faktor ist, das Verhältnis war nie ganz reibungslos. Das Verhältnis zwischen Medien und Vereinsverantwortlichen oder Clubverantwortlichen. Seit ein, zwei Jahren wird es immer schlimmer, seit eben Hasan Ismail, der Investor, immer mehr Einfluss auch bekommt in den Gremien. Der fühlt sich eben, habe ich selber auch erlebt, der fühlt sich eben sehr, sehr schnell beleidigt. Der ist sehr, sehr schnell beleidigt. Da wir die Parade zu Trump, fühlt sich nicht genug geliebt. Am Anfang war es dann immer so ein, was wollt ihr denn alle? Ich habe diesen Verein gerettet, ich habe diesen Verein 30 Millionen Euro, 40 Millionen Euro, mittlerweile sind 60 Millionen Euro wahrscheinlich irgendwie gegeben. Und ihr und die Präsidenten und ihr Journalisten zitiert mich immer. Und ich möchte doch nur geliebt werden. Heute, vor ein paar Stunden, hat Ismail einen Facebook-Post veröffentlicht, was ja sein Lieblingsmedium ist, Trump ist Twitter, Ismail ist Facebook, was er von einem Berliner Testerbüro betreuen lässt, in dem er sagt, ich habe mich in den letzten Jahren immer weiter weg davon bewegt, ein Investor zu sein, meine Interessen liegen nur daran, irgendwie die Fans glücklich zu machen. Also er möchte, und diese Argumentationsstruktur hat er schon lange, ist halt lang, er möchte einfach nur geliebt werden, er möchte der große Ismail sein und der edle Retter, der sich 60 gerettet hat, und deswegen möchte er geliebt werden und möchte respektiert werden und möchte was weiß ich was alles.
Das wollte Louis K. Thorst, glaube ich auch.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen diese Gemeindenlage, in der wir uns bewegen. Und dazu kommt eben auch da wieder Trump, dass man sich einzelne Artikel hin und wieder –mittlerweile sind wir nicht mehr bei einzelnen Artikel, sondern mittlerweile sind wir bei generell –alles, was die Medien schreiben, ist gelogen, ist manipulativ. Die Medien hätten –das einzige, was die Medien machen wollen, sei, die Fans zu manipulieren. Man solle die Medien nicht lesen, sondern nur die Vereinsnachrichten lesen und so weiter. Das ist so ein Phänomen, das gibt es so seit eineinhalb Jahren, und das wird eben immer schlimmer. Das wird immer schlimmer. Die bedienen sich dann teilweise auch tatsächlich einfach wieder genau der gleichen Sprache, die man von Pegida-Leuten, Lügenpresse und so weiter hört. Ja, und das ist einfach an einem Punkt angelangt, wo man einfach sehr schwer mit umgehen kann und es auch sehr schwer fällt oder sehr schwer fallen muss, dass man dem Ganzen irgendwie sachlich entgegensteht und trotzdem einfach nur eine sachliche Berichterstattung macht. Weil irgendwann geht es natürlich auch an die persönliche, also auf die persönliche Ebene, und irgendwann denkt man sich auch, okay, was willst du eigentlich?
Na ja, klar, das ist ja das Paradoxe durch die Lügenpresse, und es werden hier Kampagnen gegen mich gestartet, Vorwürfe, je öfter und häufiger und persönlicher auch den Journalisten gegenüber dir vorgebracht werden, desto größer wird eventuell die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass da tatsächlich etwas läuft, was zumindest eine Kampagne erinnert. Das kann man sich ja alles irgendwie psychologisch herleiten, es hat bestimmt auch mit unterschiedlichen kulturellen Hintergründen zu tun. Ismail kommt aus einer kompletten Verwirrung.
Ich bin Italiener und von meinem Denken ganz weit weg von Rassismus und nicht arabische Freunde. Ich habe das auch vor zwei, drei Jahren schon geschrieben, dass es natürlich die damalige Vereinsführung und er, natürlich gibt es da kulturelle Clash-of-culture-Problematiken und natürlich auch Missverständnisse deswegen. Da hat er mir danach vorgeworfen, ich sei ein Rassist. Und zwar persönlich auch. Das ist natürlich so, aber man darf es nicht sagen.
Okay, gut, dann möchte ich das jetzt hiermit auch, nein eigentlich will ich es nicht zurückgenommen wissen. Was soll er mir auch tun? Ich bin ein kleiner Podcast. Aber worauf ich hinauswollte war, das eine ist, dass man sich das irgendwie erklären kann und was der Verein macht oder Hasan Ismaik oder Anthony Power, der Geschäftsführer. Das liegt ja erstmal in dessen eigene Hand. Die Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist, möchte die DFL auch, dass sich ein Verein innerhalb ihrer derzeit noch 36 Bundesliga-Vereine der ersten und zweiten Liga so verhält, siehst du da die DFL in der Verantwortung, dass die da eventuell einschreiten und sagen, Moment mal, so wollen wir nicht, dass hier mit der deutschen Presse umgegangen wird? Also, ehrlich gesagt, die können das doch nicht gut finden, wenn sich ein Verein so verhält.
Die DFL findet es sicherlich nicht gut. Das Problem bei 60 ist natürlich, man kann es nicht gut finden. Das Problem bei 60 ist, dass das weit über das übliche folkloristische Maß hinausgeht, dass man die Journalisten beschimpft. Das ist ja manchmal auch ganz lustig, wenn Klopp anfängt, sich wieder den Journalisten rauszupicken. Da muss man ja auch drüber stehen und das ist für das Publikum auch ganz lustig. Was hier passiert, ist natürlich eine ganz andere Dimension. Ich glaube aber, dass das nicht der Punkt ist, wo sich die DFL jetzt großartig einschalten müsste. Ich glaube, die DFL müsste eher bei anderen Dingen das wirklich kritisch hinterfragen. Wenn man ehrlich ist, um das kurz zu sagen, dass uns Journalisten das natürlich nicht gefallen kann, dass es generell einfach common sense sein müsste, dass es nicht okay ist, was da passiert, ist die eine Sache. Aber innerhalb des Vereins, innerhalb des Clubs passieren ja Geschichten, die vielleicht nicht ganz sauber sind, die vielleicht nicht im Einklang stehen mit 50 plus 1, die vielleicht, ich sage bewusst vielleicht, man wird es auch nicht beweisen können, aber es gibt einfach, man sieht einfach, um es ganz neutral zu sagen, man sieht einfach, dass bei 60 sieht man gerade was passieren kann, wenn man einen Bestor hat und da kannst du 1000 mal 50 plus 1 haben, der kann im Endeffekt trotzdem machen, was er will. Das passiert gerade bei 60 und das sind so Sachen, wo die DFL, finde ich, tatsächlich drauf schauen müsste. Auch in der Diskussion über 50 plus 1, wir diskutieren immer noch irgendwie, was ist eigentlich mit diesen Paragrafen, soll er fallen, soll er nicht fallen und so weiter. Dabei haben wir jetzt schon ganz viele Vereine, die eigentlich 50 plus 1 untergraben und bei 60 den krassen Fall, dass 50 plus 1 da ist, dass es die Regel eigentlich gibt, aber dass du sie eigentlich nicht brauchst, weil in dem Moment, wo eine Vereinsführung eben sich mit Haut und Hahn diesen Investor einfach ergibt und macht, was er will, mehr oder weniger, ist es scheißegal, ob du 50 plus 1 hast oder nicht. Und das sind dann Dinge, finde ich, die sich die DFL anschauen sollte. Das Gleiche gilt für was aber geschehen ist oder was geschieht für Lizenzierungsgeschichten. Das Gleiche gilt eben für Geschichten wie, wenn ein eben erst eingesetzter Geschäftsführer und Sportdirektor gefeuert wird und der Investor sich bei einer Pässekonferenz hinstellt und sagt, wir als Aufsichtsrat der KGAA, also der Fußballgesellschaft, dürfen entlassen. Und dann kannst du ihnen nur sagen, sorry, nee, schauen deine Satzungen, darfst du nicht. Ist nicht deine Aufgabe, den Geschäftsführer kann man das im Süden entlassen und so weiter. Da werden eben Regeln gebrochen oder da werden augenscheinlich Regeln gebrochen. Und das sind Dinge, mit denen sich die DFL beschäftigen sollte, finde ich. Diese Mediengeschichte ist doof, ist hässlich, ist peinlich, aber ist, glaube ich, auch am Ende des Tages dann tatsächlich auch irgendwo ein Medienthema.
Ja, ist so ein bisschen die Spitze des Eisbergs. Deswegen habe ich es jetzt als Anlass genommen, über Sechzig zu sprechen. Wie hat denn Ismail das geschafft, sich diesen Verein so einzuverleiben, ohne dass es auf dem Papier möglich wäre? Hängt das damit zusammen, dass es halt einfach bei Sechzig immer gleich ums Existenzielle geht und man deswegen von Anfang an in einer wahnsinnigen Abhängigkeit von irgendwelchen Darlehen von ihm stand und so weiter?
Klar, also das ist zum einen, zum anderen aber eben auch der Verein als sich, der Club an sich, der eben auf der einen Seite nach der Bundesliga lächzt. Wir sind seit 2004 nicht mehr in der Bundesliga und sind immer noch nicht angekommen in der zweiten Liga, in den Capsen, vieler Handelnder, dann natürlich auch, dass man eben auch gesehen hat, dieser ewige Streit zwischen den Funktionären, in den Strukturen, in den Gremien und so weiter und irgendwann und dann mischt auch noch dieser Investor mit, der eben auch nicht gerade unstreitlustig ist und irgendwann kommst du dann halt auch an einen Punkt, wo es dann wieder existenziell wird, auch Geld, im Sinne von Geld existenziell. Irgendwann bist du auch an dem Punkt, wo der Investor, der Hauptanteilseigner so viel Geld reingeschossen hat, dass du genau weißt, du könntest es nie mehr raus, du könntest es nie mehr zurückzahlen. Du wirst wahrscheinlich nie mehr einen anderen Anteilseigner finden, weil er dann diese ganzen Schulden erst mal bezahlen müsste. Du hast auch irgendwie keine wirklichen Alternativen mehr, also versuchen wir jetzt halt mal, das zu tun, was er will. Und an dem Punkt bist du jetzt gerade. Na ja, in erster Linie aufsteigen und geliebt werden. Was er dann will, weiß ich nicht. Es ist schwer zu sagen und ich glaube, alles, was man da sagt, ist vielleicht auch rechtlich relevant. Und solange man es nicht beweisen kann, ist es dann wahrscheinlich auch blöd, wenn man es sagt. Aber in erster Linie will er natürlich aufsteigen, will natürlich auch der erste arabische Investor in Deutschland sein, der es geschafft hat. Der dann irgendwie auch zu Hause seinen Freunden sagen kann, hey, ich bin hier Bundesliga-Chef, in der Bundesliga-Chef am liebsten, will er natürlich irgendwie auch im Europa Cup spielen und so weiter. Und das, was er immer wieder sagt, natürlich ist er auch ein Narzisst irgendwo. Also natürlich will er wirklich geliebt werden. Und natürlich will er auch, dass man ihm immer wieder sagt, wie toll das ist und danke, hasse und super gemacht.
Gut, das ist ja sehr menschlich. Also ich höre es auch sehr gerne, wenn die mir sagen, dass ich ihn wiedergebe.
Genau, das ist erst mal sehr menschlich. Wenn man es aber immer wieder auf Facebook schreiben muss, dass mein einziges Ziel ist, geliebt zu werden und mein einziges Ziel ist, die Fans glücklich zu machen, wird es halt irgendwann auffällig und dann bist du nicht mehr weit davon entfernt zu diesem Narzisstentum. Aber auch das ist eine Ferndiagnose. Ich habe ihn ein paar Mal getroffen, ein paar Mal mich mit ihm zu unterhalten. Der ist eigentlich ganz nett im persönlichen Gespräch. Das andere ist, und das ist eben das, was so undurchsichtig ist, was er jetzt aktuell möchte, ist noch mehr Anteile, noch mehr Einfluss, noch mehr Macht. Also er hat aktuell 60 Prozent der Aktien. Davon sind aber nur, nee, Quatsch. Am Anfang waren 60 Prozent der Aktien, davon waren aber nur 49 Prozent stimmberechtigte Anteile. Dadurch, dass er in den letzten Jahren aber immer wieder Darlehen gegeben hat, um strukturelle Defizite auszugleichen, um Spieler zu kaufen, um die Allianz-Renner zu bezahlen und so weiter, musste 60 irgendwann laut DFL-Statuten diese Darlehen umwandeln. Es gibt eine Regel, du darfst als Verein in den Bundesliegen nicht zwei Jahre hintereinander Verlust ausweisen. Im Sinne von dein negatives Eigenkapital. Du darfst Verlust ausweisen, aber deine Schulden, dein Schuldenstand darf nicht steigen. Deswegen hat Sechzig da so eine Art Finanztrick gefunden und Eastmike wandelt meistens pünktlich mit bestimmte Summe von Darlehen um in sogenannte Genussrechte. Das sind auch Schulden, aber kannst du bilanciell als Eigenkapital werten. Es ist kompliziert, du brauchst fast einen BWL-Abschluss, um das zu verstehen. Das Einzige, was in diesem Zusammenhang wichtig ist, ist, dass diese Genussrechte irgendwann, wenn sie nicht zurückgezahlt werden, umgewandelt werden können in Stimmen bzw. in stimmhafte Anteile. Das ist das, was sie gemacht haben. Deswegen ist Mike momentan 60% der Aktien hält, 60% der stimmhaften Aktien. Das reicht ihm aber nicht. Im Dezember gab es eine Sitzung des Hauptausschusses, das ist praktisch die zwei Gesellschaften, also der East Investor auf der einen Seite und der Verein auf der anderen Seite, in dem Wiederdarlehen umgewandelt wurde in Genussrechten und da haben die beiden Parteien vereinbart, dass man neue Anteile schaffen möchte, beziehungsweise sie haben erst einmal vereinbart, dass sie sich eben darüber verständigen wollen, dass der Investor irgendwie mehr Anteile bekommen soll. Darüber müsste eine Mitgliederversammlung jetzt entscheiden, aber die wird im März stattfinden. Das heißt, ISMAI könnte dann am Ende dieses Prozesses möglicherweise mehr als 75% der Anteile haben. Das ist laut DFL trotz 50 plus 1 erlaubt. 50 plus 1 heißt nicht, das ist nicht wörtlich zu verstehen, dass man praktisch 50% plus eine Aktie haben muss an einem Fußballunternehmen, sondern dass der Verein immer, dass der Verein immer bei bestimmten Entscheidungen das letzte Wort haben muss, sonst könnte zum Beispiel Leipzig Red Bull nicht 100% der Anteile halten, sonst könnte in Hoffenheim nicht HOP 100% der Anteile halten.
Aber wer ist denn der Verein, also wenn du im Verein peu à peu alle entscheidende Positionen durch Leute besetzt, die dir mindestens gewogen sind? Also wenn ich mir angucke, Geschäftsführer ist ja Anthony Power, der bis auf seinen tollen Namen, bisher weniger durch tolle Dinge aufgefallen ist.
Ja, bei dem man noch nicht mal weiß, ehrlicherweise bis heute, weil es noch nicht im Handelsregister veröffentlicht wurde, man weiß gar nicht, ob der bei 60 angestellt ist oder ob der nicht bei einer von X-Mikes Firmen angestellt ist.
Ach.
Er ist ja nur kommissarisch, deswegen weiß man das bis heute nicht. Sein Vorgänger als kommissarischer Geschäftsführer, Red Gerges, der ungefähr ein halbes Jahr da war und jetzt nur noch Marketing machen darf, das ist ein X-Mike Vertrauter, der war nicht bei 60 angestellt, sondern eben bei einer von X-Mikes Tochtergesellschaften. Und er hat sich dann im Auftrag seines Chefs praktisch um 1860 gekümmert. Ja, so kann man eben auch so, so kann man zum Beispiel auf 50 plus 1 umgehen. Der darf halt nicht auf Dauer das sein, sondern muss natürlich interdienstmäßig das machen, damit man immer schön sagen kann, ja wir stehen ja eine langfristige Lösung an und dann wird es auch wieder regelkonform sein und so weiter. Aber so könnte man zum Beispiel 50 plus 1 auch erstmal umgehen.
Gibt es denn noch jemanden im Verein, wo du sagen würdest, der jetzt an entscheidender Position sitzt, der steht noch ein bisschen für das alte 60, die Zeit vor dem Investor und der könnte vielleicht auch mal gegensteuern oder sind solche Leute gar nicht mehr zu finden?
Also sicherlich gibt es unter den Mitgliedern noch diese Menschen, die sitzen ja nicht im Aufsichtsrat. Ja genau, also man muss da auch da unterscheiden zwischen Aufsichtsrat, also zwischen Gremien der KGAA, sprich der Fußballgesellschaft und zwischen den Gremien des Gesamtvereins, wo ja auch die Ski-Abteilung ist, wo Lidl Strasse jetzt zum Beispiel gestern den Parallelslandung gewonnen hat, wo die Turnabteilungen sind und so weiter. In den Gremien des Gesamtvereins gibt es schon noch ist Mike Kritiker weniger als früher, aber es gibt sie noch. In den Gremien der Fußball-Abteilung, der Profi-Abteilung, also der Profi-Fußball-Abteilung, gibt es mittlerweile da keine Kritiker mehr. Da sitzen die Ismaks-Leute und dann sitzt da halt ein Präsident, ein Vereinspräsident, Casalet, der in seinen anderthalb Jahren Amtszeit noch nie aufgefallen wäre mit irgendetwas, was irgendwie ismaksitisch sein könnte, hätte sein können, im Gegenteil, der eben ein Mensch ist, der sich auf eine Pressekonferenz hinstellt, nachdem man irgendwie den Trainer entlastet hat und den Geschäftsführer absolviert hat, Thomas Achin, was eigentlich genau in seinen Verantwortungsbereich fällt und dann sagt, mich brauchen sie nicht zu fragen, fragen sie, hast du nicht Smile, ich bin nur der Vereinspräsident. Also wo man sagen muss, naja, du bist halt der Vereinspräsident, also eigentlich wärst du der Einzige, der den jetzt hätte entlassen können, den Geschäftsführer. Und dann natürlich, wenn dann die DFL nachfragt, da gab es ja eine Untersuchung, natürlich haben dann alle EV-Vertreter gesagt, diese Entscheidung sei in den Gremien gemeinsam getroffen worden. Das ist natürlich dann immer der Trick.
Ja gut, klar. Du willst dich ja auch nicht angreifbar machen. Es wirkt jetzt zwar auch nicht so, als stünde die DFL da Gewehr bei Fuß, aber...
Die hat halt auch, also die hat, die hat ehrlicherweise auch nicht wirklich eine Handhabe. Also das muss man auch einfach sehen. Deswegen, deswegen sage ich aber eigentlich...
Warum hat sie keine Handhabe? Kann nicht die DFL vom Punktabzug bis zu Lizenzentzug eigentlich alles machen, was für einen Verein wichtig ist?
Ja, wenn du halt nachweisen kannst, dass da illegale Machenschaften oder was Illegale, wenn du halt genau nachweisen kannst, dass da machen, dass da an Statuten vorbei Dinge passiert sind. Also 60 hat ja letztes Jahr, haben sie zum Beispiel eine hohe Geldstrafe bekommen, weil sie eben ihre Schulden nicht abgeben oder ihre Schulden vergrößert hatten. Weil diesmal die Darlehen nicht umgewandelt hatte, weil er sich da gerade mit dem damaligen Präsidenten gestritten hatte. Wenn sie das dieses Jahr wieder so gemacht hätten, also wenn Ismail dieses Jahr nicht umgewandelt hätte, was er am 29. Dezember getan hat, dann hätte es Punktabzüge gegeben. Die nächste Konsequenz wäre dann möglicherweise ein Lizenzentzug gewesen. Klar, sollte jetzt auffallen, rein hypothetisch gesprochen, dass das im Zuge dieser vielen Transferströme, die jetzt gerade passieren, weil 60er jetzt auch anfangen, zum Verschiebebahnhof von Fußballprofis zu werden. Momentan haben sie 34 Leute im Kader, von denen jetzt 5 im Winter dazukamen und dann werden im Sommer wieder 10 gehen und so weiter. Sollte dann dort auffallen, dass möglicherweise da Dinge passieren würden, die nicht mit dem Statut der DFL in Einklang stünden, dann könnte die DFL was tun, genauso wie bei allen anderen Vereinen auch. Aber solange eben die entscheidenden, handelnden Personen des EVs immer sagen, naja, ja, mag sein, dass das ein bisschen blöd aussieht, dass wir jetzt einen vierten Geschäftsführer in eineinhalb Jahren haben, aber das war unsere Entscheidung, kann die DFL nichts machen. Also die DFL ist ja nicht die Polizei, um Menschen vor sich selbst zu schützen.
Klar, soll sie letztlich ja auch nicht sein, aber interessanterweise könnten wir ja jetzt dann nach, ich glaube, einer halben Stunde Gespräch, dann doch mal wenigstens auch kurz über Sportliche reden. Das zeigt ja schon alles, wie es gerade um 60 steht. Wenn wir uns jetzt mal aktuell angucken, dann hat 60 durch ein 2 zu 1 gegen Fürth den 13. Tabellenplatz sich geholt und jetzt drei Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz. Und gerade im Winter ist viel passiert. Es wurde vorm Winter schon Vitor Pereira geholt, ein renommierter Trainer mit einer sportlichen Vita, die aufhorchen lässt. War bei Porto, war Olympiakos Pereira.
Im übrigen tatsächlich Pep Guardiola sehr schätzt. Weil Pereira vor allem wegen seines taktischen Könnens. Ich weiß nicht, was er motivationstechnisch drauf hat. Ich glaube, der ist nicht ganz einfach so als Mensch.
Hat ja auch schon Titel gewonnen. Und jetzt wurden viele, viele Spieler geholt. Und Pereira hat auch gesagt, er ist nicht gekommen, um nicht abzusteigen. Und damit hat er nicht gemeint, er wird sich jetzt vorhin den Abstiegskampf reinwerfen. Sondern er hat damit eher signalisiert, also mein Blick geht eher nach oben in der Tabelle. Auch typisch 60 ehrlich gesagt, so für den Außenstehenden. Was ist ihm jetzt passiert? Kannst du mal erklären, was jetzt so im Winter passiert ist? Auch, was du gemeint hast mit verschiebe Bahnhof für Spieler. Das ist ja, also 34 Spieler im Kader ist ja krass.
Ja, also was passiert ist, wir haben jetzt fünf Spieler geholt, relativ auf die letzten Drücke. Also der Pereda ist 16 Tage ins Zähnenslager gefahren nach Portugal. Hat sich da aber eigentlich bloß die Mannschaft angeschaut, die bis jetzt da war. Und ist dann relativ schnell auch zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass der Kader ihm eigentlich zu groß ist. Er arbeitet gerne mit kleinen Kader. Damals hatte er 60, glaube ich, 30 Spiele im Kader oder 31. Dann hat man auf den letzten Drücker jetzt noch fünf Spieler verpflichtet. Davon zwei vom Pawellenführer der portugiesischen zweiten Liga. Davon ein Torschützenkönig aus Norwegen. Davon ein 21-jähriger Ganaer, der gerade beim Afrika Cup spielt. So, diese Art von Spielern plus einen Spieler, Abdullah Ibar, der 26 ist und, glaube ich, jetzt schon beim neunten Verein ist und der immer dem FC Porto gehörte und halt irgendwie von Verein zu Verein zu Verein verlieben wird. Und haben jetzt, haben dann noch zwei abgegeben und haben jetzt 34 Spiele im Kader. Wie gut diese Spieler sind, die geholt wurden, ich weiß es nicht. Deine Positionsbezogen und von ihren Charakteristiken, was man so sieht, scheinen sie zumindest im periodistischen System zu passen. Und man weiß, dass Pereira da schon auch ein großes Mitspracherecht hatte, beziehungsweise es gibt da kein Sportdirektor, also wahrscheinlich hat er sie auch maßgeblich geholt. Was mir persönlich ein wenig Sorge bereitet, ist tatsächlich diese riesige Fluktuation an Spielern, die bei 60 Grad herrscht. Das heißt, man holt jede Transferperiode fünf bis sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn Spieler. Klar, auch weil es sportlich nicht funktioniert, auch weil man in jeder Transferperiode mehr oder weniger den Trainer entlässt und austauscht. Jeder neue Trainer, das heißt V-Modelle, genau. In diesem Zusammenhang ist aber ein bisschen besorgniserregend, dass Ismaik ganz offen damit umgeht, dass er als Berater, als einen seiner wichtigsten Berater, Khiya Durabchan hat. Khiya Durabchan ist ein englischer Iraner oder iranischer Engländer, dem unter anderem mal Carlos Teres gehört hat. Tatsächlich gehört er. Das ist einer der Pioniere der Third-Party Ownership, die mittlerweile verboten ist. Wenn man mal Khiya Durabchan und Portsmouth googelt, erkennt man ein wenig, wie dieser Mann gearbeitet hat. Portsmouth ist mittlerweile in der vierten Liga, nachdem Durabchan und seine Freunde da irgendwie durchgezogen sind. Der ist ein Spieler-Geschäftsmann, muss man so zu sagen. Der ist ein klassischer Spielerberater, der macht sein Geld, nachdem es ja nicht mehr erlaubt ist, dieses Anteil an Spielern zu haben. Er macht sein Geld mit Beratung von Investoren, mit Vermittlung von Spielertransfers. Er berät den, sagt dem, du holt den und den und den. Er bekommt dafür eine Provision, die aber nicht in einer Transfer-Summe drin ist, sondern bekommt die Provision direkt vom Investor. Was der auch macht, ist, er gibt Kredite an Fußballvereine, vielleicht auch an Investoren. Also man weiß ja nicht, mit welchem Geld Ismaik diese Darlehen bezahlt. Also es ist durchaus eine Möglichkeit, ich sage nicht denkbar, es ist durchaus eine Möglichkeit, dass er vielleicht auch Geld von anderen Seiten bekommt, selber. Und natürlich arbeiten dann solche Menschen, wie Juhab Jahn eben, verdienen sie an jedem Transfer mit, völlig legal, völlig legal erst mal. Natürlich ist es dann natürlich auch in deren Interesse, dass man möglichst hohe Fluktuation hat, um eben auch auf seine Kosten zu kommen, um seine Kosten rein zu bekommen. Dass das sportlich funktioniert, es kann sportlich funktionieren, wenn man mal Glück hat und die Richtigen da hat. Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht der sportliche Erfolg, der da im Vordergrund ist, sondern tatsächlich erstmal das Business. Das ist ein bisschen meine Sorge, also vielleicht funktioniert das nicht. Bis auf den dänischen Stürmer Gütke hatte ich von diesen anderen vier, die sie geholt haben, noch nie was gehört. Ich weiß es nicht, vielleicht sind es super Spieler, vielleicht funktioniert das, vielleicht funktioniert es auch nicht. Wenn man sich die letzten zwölf Jahre anschaut, wird es wahrscheinlich eher nicht funktionieren. So pessimistisch muss man glaube ich sein mittlerweile, aber ich glaube es ist nicht das vorrangige Ziel, sondern erstmal geht es darum, zumindest von Eastmikes Beratern und vielleicht auch von Eastmikes selbst, ich weiß es nicht, geht es glaube ich erstmal darum, ein bisschen Business zu machen.
Und was beobachtest du so, was macht das mit dem Verein, dass es da große Wanderungsströme auch innerhalb der Mitglieder gibt und das Stadion bei weitem nicht mehr ausverkauft ist, das weiß glaube ich inzwischen jeder Fußballfan. Aber wie ist so dein Gefühl, wie die Mitglieder darauf reagieren? Es gab zwischenzeitlich eine Zeit, wo ich den Eindruck hatte, man hatte gar nicht so große Probleme mit Eastmike, weil er schon so ein bisschen als einziger Ausweg in vielleicht eine etwas goldenere Zukunft fiel.
Also ich glaube, der Großteil der Mitglieder, also da wird sich im März dann zeigen, bei dieser außerordentlichen Mitgliederversammlung, wo es dann wohl um mehr Anteile für ihn geht. Ich glaube, der Großteil der Mitglieder steht hinter ihm, auch weil man sich wünscht und er träumt, einfach aufzusteigen und sagt, er hat uns gerettet, sondern wer zahlt, schafft an und so weiter. Ich beobachte natürlich bei den jüngeren, also gerade den jüngeren Münchnern, Hiesinger vor allem, das ist jetzt tatsächlich dann auch eher ein Stadtteilphänomen, dass es da durchaus immer noch Kids gibt, die lösen werden, die gerade ein bisschen das Problem haben, dass es dort keine funktionierende Ultra-Bewegung gibt bzw. dass sich die Ultras auch aufgelöst haben. Und jetzt gerade Neugründen, man weiß nicht, wohin das führt, ob das erfolgreich ist. Die sind aber in krasse Opposition zu Hiesinger, weil die sagen halt, das ist absolute Scheiße. Grundsätzlich ist es so, dass die Stimmung im Stadion halt richtig schlecht ist, richtig mies ist, weil es eben keine Ultras mehr gibt, dass immer weniger hingehen, ja. Wobei sich das, glaube ich, ändern würde, in dem Moment, wo sie wirklich Erfolg hätten, dann wäre, glaube ich, zumindest, der Münchner an sich ist ja mehr so ein Eventi. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo sie gewinnen würden, würden sie dann hingehen. Die Frage ist, ob dann die hingehen würden, die wirklich für Stimmung sorgen würden. Also dieses alte Sechzig, was die Löwen-Fans immer noch behaupten, dass aber Quatsch ist, von wegen 15.000 Blaue machen mehr Radau als 75.000 Rote, das ist halt leider vorbei.
Das ist Quatsch.
Ihr, der das sagt, war wahrscheinlich seit fünf Jahren nicht mehr im Stadion. Also das ist Quatsch. Das ist so der eine Punkt. Und der andere Punkt ist natürlich, dass du halt immer mehr von, man weiß ja gar nicht mehr, wofür Sechzig steht. Ich meine, ein Investor, der halt kann natürlich 50.000 mal sagen, ich bin ein echter Löwe und ich möchte, dass die Fans glücklich und stolz sind. Aber eigentlich keine Ahnung, wofür du stehst. Jetzt hast du eine Mannschaft, die aus Spielern zusammengewürfelt wird, aus irgendwie 54 Nationen. Gut, du hast auch in Bayern mit Stefan Eigner. Aber auch da kannst du nicht sagen, Sechzig hatte in den letzten Jahren zumindest eine gute Jugendarbeit. Siehst du auch nicht mehr. Die Jungen sind jetzt Afrikaner, was auch toll sein kann. Also keine Frage, darum geht es gar nicht. Aber man weiß nicht so richtig, wofür Sechzig jetzt noch stehen soll, imagemäßig. Alle halbe Jahre kommt ein neuer Trainer, alle dreiviertel Jahre kommt ein neuer Präsident und so weiter. Das heißt, du verlierst natürlich mit jedem Wechsel in der Führung und mit jedem weiteren Jahr in der zweiten Liga extrem an Attraktivität. Und du verlierst jetzt aktuell extrem an dem, wofür du eigentlich stehst, was eigentlich der Lübe sein möchte und was der Lübe ist.
Kannst du mir das mit der Jugendarbeit erklären? Also, dass Sechzig eine gute Jugendarbeit hat, das sieht man ja allein an den Spielern, die gegangen sind. Was ich aber nicht so ganz verstehen kann, ist, warum hat man die auch als E-Smack dann irgendwann da war und Geld nicht mehr das vorrangige Problem war, nicht halten können? Also die prominentesten Namen, die von Sechzig kamen und dann aber den Sprung bei einem anderen Verein geschafft haben, sind Julian Weigel, Lars Bender, Julian Baumgartlinger, Kevin Volland. Marcel Schäfer, Sven Bender ja auch. Also gibt es ganz, ganz viele, die man nennen kann.
Ja, es gibt ganz viele. Ich meine, die Bender-Zwölinge konntest du halt nicht halten, weil die halt viel zu gut waren damals.
Das war noch eine andere Zeit.
Und du nicht in der zweiten Liga weiter spielen konntest und vielleicht noch ein Jahr in der zweiten Liga nicht spielen konntest, dann hättest du sie verkaufen müssen. Dann hättest du sie ja vielleicht teurer verkaufen müssen. Klar, damals hat man eben Spieler häufig unter Wert verkauft. Weil man es musste? Genau, weil man es musste, weil man irgendwie die Löcher stopfen musste. Wie du sagst, das ist momentan jetzt nicht das ganz große Problem. Die einzigen zwei, die jetzt aber seit Eastmark da ist, verkauft wurden und eingeschlagen sind in der Bundesliga, sind ja Volland und Weigel. Bei Volland war es so, dass der irgendwann keinen Bock mehr hatte. Also auch auf Zweite Liga. Der hat halt einfach wahnsinnig stark gespielt. Und dann kam Hoffenheim und hat ihm gesagt, pass auf, hier kannst du dich entwickeln. Und das hat er ja auch geschafft. Also der war einfach zu gut. Den mussten sie nicht verkaufen. Also aus finanziellen Gründen mussten sie ihn nicht verkaufen, aber der musste halt einfach in die Bundesliga. Bei Weigel war es so, Weigel war ein Opfer, ein typisches 60-Opfer. Also da gab es diesen Staat in der Vereinführung, Trainerentlassungen, dieser arme 18-Jährige, der als hochtalentiert galt, und den du auch angesehen hast, dass er hochtalentiert ist, kam nicht so richtig zum Zug. Vier Trainer in einer Saison, der eine lässt ihn dar spielen, der andere lässt ihn dar spielen. Dann baust du halt irgendwann immer mehr ab. Und dann kommt Russell Dortmund und sagt, ja komm, wir geben euch irgendwie drei Millionen, also dann nimm, dann verkaufst du ihn halt. Also das war, da waren auch ehrlicherweise die wenigsten Fans, Fans sind ja oft auch nicht weitsichtig, aber die wenigsten Fans haben gesagt, was soll das, das soll, und das kann doch nicht sein, sondern die meisten haben gesagt, ja Gott sei Dank haben wir noch so viel Geld dafür bekommen.
Was wahrscheinlich auch mit dieser Taxifahrt von ihm zu tun hat.
Ja, die Taxifahrt war es, nee, es war mehr halt, der Bonis kam und wurde gefeuert, der Final kam und wurde gefeuert, es war halt einfach zu viel los in dem Jahr.
Nee, ich meine, dass die Fans damit jetzt nicht so ein großes Problem hatten, dass es ging. Also kurz für die Hörer, die es nicht mehr...
Nee, er hat ehrlicherweise noch nicht so gut gespielt. Du hast halt in jedem Spiel einfach diese enormen Ansätze gesehen, aber er hat auch zu viel Verantwortung. Also ich meine, du kannst halt nicht im 18-Jährigen sagen, du führst jetzt diese Mannschaft in die Bundesliga, und sitzt da im zentralen Mittelfeld und hast aber keinen Spieler, der dich gescheit anspielen kann und keiner läuft richtig. Und dann ist da Moritz Stockelkamp, der ein begnalender Techniker ist, aber selber wahrscheinlich nicht weiß, wohin er läuft während so eines Spiels. Und dann willst du dem den Ball zupassen, und dann ist das schon ganz woanders. Also es war halt schwierig für ihn, auch in dieser Mannschaft war es schwierig für ihn. Und dann noch mit den Begleitumständen, und dann sitzt er halt irgendwann da und weiß nicht mehr, wie der geschieht.
Also kurz für die Hörer, die es nicht mehr wissen, Julian Weigl, damals 18-jähriger Kapitän, hat auf einer Taxifahrt mit ein paar anderen Spielen nicht in besten Tönen über den Verein gesprochen, und der Taxifahrer war wohl er blauer. Und so kam das dann alles raus. Das ist die Geschichte dahinter. Ja, Filippo, jetzt, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man da jetzt eine Decke drauf machen kann. Vermutlich wird der Deckel auch nie so ganz draufgehen auf 1860. Aber du hast vorhin schon so ein bisschen über dein Verhältnis zum Verein gesprochen, auch jenseits vom journalistischen her. Was glaubst du denn in fünf Jahren, was für Schlagzeilen werden wir dann über 1860 lesen? Das ist jetzt natürlich höchst spekulativ, aber...
Es ist tatsächlich höchst spekulativ. Ich glaube, aber in der zweiten Liga werden sie nicht mehr spielen. In fünf Jahren.
Weil sie in welche Richtung entschwunden sind?
Na ja, weil sie vielleicht, ich meine, irgendwann, natürlich, wenn du jedes Jahr 10, 20 Millionen Euro irgendwie reinsteckst, wahrscheinlich hast du dann irgendwann auch Glück und steigst vielleicht auf. Also das ist die eine Geschichte. Ob ich dann glaube, ist die andere Frage. Aber das ist natürlich möglich. Die andere Geschichte ist halt einfach, dass das alles halt jedem irgendwie um die Ohren fliegt und du dann halt sonst wo bist, aber nicht im bezahlten Fußball.
Und dann gucken wir auch mal, wie sich die Stadionfrage bis dahin gelöst hat. Abschließende Frage. Du bist ja auch in so einer Mittelrolle zwischen Herz und Hirn, sage ich jetzt mal. Macht es als Journalist eigentlich Spaß, über einen solchen Chaos-Verein zu berichten?
Also ich glaube im Moment würde es mir keinen Spaß machen. Außer, außer, das sage ich ganz klar, außer ich hätte so gute Infos. Also ich sage mal so, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie tatsächlich Löwenreporter noch wäre, der diesen Verein total begleiten würde, wäre es jetzt natürlich mein Anspruch und auch mein journalistischer Anspruch. Und deswegen würde es dann natürlich auch trotzdem Spaß machen, da ein paar Skandale ans Licht zu bringen, was ja funktioniert. Oder zumindest Skandale, zumindest Dinge aufzudecken. Die tägliche Arbeit mit der Mannschaft oder das tägliche Geschäft würde mir momentan keinen Spaß machen, im Gegenteil. All die Jahre, die ich das gemacht habe, hat es natürlich Spaß gemacht. Weil natürlich ist es toll, einen Verein zu betreuen, journalistisch oder journalistisch zu begleiten, bei dem halt immer was los ist, egal wie verrückt es ist. Und dann sitzt man halt auch irgendwie mal ein paar Mal im Jahr nachts im Zweifel auch bei minus zehn Grad bis fünf Uhr morgens vor der Geschäftsstelle und wartet, dass irgendeine außerordentliche Aufsichtsratssitzung vorbeigeht, von der man zufällig gehört hat, um den Leuten dann irgendwie abzupassen, um noch irgendwie ein halbes Zitat zu bekommen, dass man dann auf seine Website schreibt. Das habe ich alles gemacht und das war natürlich auch irgendwie lustig und war auch schön. Momentan glaube ich, also momentan hätte ich da glaube ich vielleicht weniger Lust drauf, sage ich mal so.
Naja, dann bist du ja gut platziert am Bodensee. Philippo, vielen herzlichen Dank, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast, mir da mal ein paar Dinge zu 1860 zu erklären und vielleicht auch dem Hörer das eine oder andere Licht aufgehen zu lassen. Philippo Carteidou von der schwäbischen Zeitung Ressortleiter Sport bei Twitter at Philippo Carteidou. Da lohnt es sich sehr, ihm zu folgen.
Sehr, sehr gerne und Grüße.
Danke, Grüße zurück aus Giesing, grüß dich.
Grüße an die Lieblingsstadt.
Ja, ja, ich sitze direkt in Obergiesing. Liebe Hörer, das war's. Hört gerne auch in die Schlusskonferenz und ins Tribünengespräch. Empfehlt uns weiter, wenn ihr mögt. Und ihr könnt uns auch finanziell unterstützen unter rasenfunk.de/unterstützen. Und das war er, der Kurzpass 38 mit dem Thema 1860 München. Und was ist da los? Mal gucken, wie viel wir dazu noch machen. Macht's gut, ciao.